thumbs I got thumbs in both directions
already warm up your thumbs got that
thumb water is going um yeah battlefield
one has the highest thumbed up trailer
in the history of youtube trailer yeah
and history YouTube em arm pointed this
out a couple days ago and also call of
duty on the opposite side yep but it is
one of the most thumbed down I think
game trailers so this can come from like
a variety of places also there it's like
perfect that clip click base for a video
game websites new store you don't even
like it sounds great but let's kind of
talk about the reaction to both of these
games sort of outside of that a little
bit and first of all let's talk about
bout fill one we did a sort of a
breakdown after that announcement you
went down and saw some awesome gameplay
stuff we've already talked about that
you can check it out on youtube and
GameSpot and but the reaction tonight
trailer were you surprised that i
learned about how I refreshing or how
into it people were considering it is
you know it's a it's a war we've not
really seen much of yeah i think what
one hasn't been done all that well at
least in American cinema and I was doing
a lot of research after that came out I
noticed there are quite a few British
movies which what makes sense and I
think it also hasn't been that explored
in video games just because of probably
the misconception that the weapons would
be fairly boring yes um so yeah I gotta
say that it caught me off guard I
thought maybe they were gonna go back to
World War two or maybe do Korea or
Vietnam it's surprising in a very good
way just because now I'm excited like
it's a campaign about a war that I don't
honestly know a lot about right um and
that's exciting it means that I you have
an opportunity to not only enjoy
yourself from a shooter perspective but
also you know learn something or had or
experience something that maybe you only
ever saw in black and white history
class films or you know to me that's
exciting yeah and that is new it's where
do you said actually because when I
think about playing the original call of
duty and like I remember feeling like
really upset at the when you like
storing the right star
I can bring up like the Soviet flag and
stuff like it's quite an effect like for
me as a teen as a young sort of teenage
boy like that was how I learned a lot of
our world war two in the same way like
Band of Brothers was a like Saving
Private Ryan like taught an entire
generation what happened on the Normandy
beaches who might have known otherwise
and do you think there's anything to be
said about that that like people have
this sort of emotional reaction to
something when it has actually happened
and existed in a way that they don't
when we started going to the world of
like sci-fi yeah for sure I mean when I
was I was pretty young on the first call
did he came out and I remember my dad
whose dad was in the Pacific Theater
during world war two was actually pretty
uncomfortable with me playing war
regimes yeah because I hit close to home
with him and now I have a brother who's
done three tours in Iraq and two in
Afghanistan he's completely fine playing
like battlefield 4 modern warfare 3 or
whatever I think it it couldn't closer
to home and that's why World War 1
itself I'm really excited for the
multiplayer I'm actually pretty excited
for I've read about and like I actually
took like a class on world war one and
it was because I didn't know much about
it was cited I actually the more thing
about the single-player it's a cool
opportunity to kind of shed light on it
and I'm hoping they don't video games
play a huge part I'm not saying I don't
like war games I play a lot of work
games played a lot of shooters but video
games in the modern day play a huge part
in how we kind of romantic eyes Dwarfs
though right and like with so many
people playing games now and I'm hoping
maybe with this game they'll take the
opportunity to kind of show how world
war 1 itself was like no one knew why we
this is this was the war when we realize
we need to stop doing this and like yeah
because world war two was very much more
black and white you know good versus
evil world war one there were so many
different reasons like sinking of
Lusitania there was the Archduke
Ferdinand assassination there's the fact
that Germany had the plan of attack the
Schlieffen Plan what do they call him in
like planned out decades in advance
before World War one and I'm interested
to see if they can actually use this
setting to kind of push a good story and
but good story as in you know like not
to make use of all the [ __ ] that went
down but yeah maybe kind of shed more
light on it because a lot of people
don't know about world war one now it's
overshadowed by World War two in terms
of you know how like like I said like
how almost romantic it was yeah I mean
yeah World War two sort of has close to
culturally its impact I mean we just add
another star wars movie and that's
basically i'm sharing allegory for two
yeah it's fascinating to think that you
know these are your right like film for
years cinema was what sort of emblazoned
the cultural impression of what we'd
like you think about Vietnam and
Apocalypse Now and and another movies
like that like you know full metal
jacket and stuff and that's how we sort
of remember these things and video games
have started in and out and I mean I
sort of always felt uncomfortable
playing some of the call of duty games
set in in the Middle East yeah because I
thought that there was a sort of an
attempt to create the same black and
white have sort of idea we had of like
other old Wars the way we think about
old Wars and those sort of productive
terms in a place where that really
doesn't necessarily apply and did you
ever guys feel that way about some of
the more modern sort of call of duty
games and maybe more particular actually
the medal of honor game that came as a
warfighter yeah yeah I I remember I was
actually playing that while my brother
was in Iraq or something so that was you
know I was in the Navy as well so I was
in the air for Air Force sorry yeah yeah
I don't remember specifics about
warfighter I remember being definitely
kind of doing that though making it more
of a US versus them mentality for what I
mean from what I played I don't know
I've had more issues with some of the
weight film has portrayed right in
modern war I think it's been too much
like you know rah go America everybody's
evil and it's sort of undercut the
complexity of the Middle East and to
bring that back around the complexity of
the Middle East although that area of
the world's I've been complex a lot of
the modern complexity comes from the
fall of the Ottoman Empire right or one
so going back to battlefield one like
you have an opportunity to explore sort
of the creation of the modern day
situations like a lot of the borders on
the map in the Middle East right now
we're just drawn by some people after at
the end of world or one they're just
like yep here's pen nope not looks good
let's put a line here and they just they
group together peoples who had no
business being grouped together I mean
you say Ottoman Empire to most people
they think of something that existed
like centuries ago not yes than a
century ago and that's why people are
always saying there's like these what if
scenarios if the Nazis won World War two
but you look back our world today exists
so much because of World War one
up would be unrecognizable if we like
were to look at some other timeline
where you know the Austrians took Italy
or you know the Germans actually pushed
into Paris like they they almost very
closely did but screwed it up because
someone made a bad decision from a
strategic standpoint but yeah that's the
setting itself i'm actually the more
think about it the more I'm excited for
the single player because a the single
player they said there's gonna be more
like multiplayer in the sandbox
structure yeah which I'm hoping they
actually really go for that and it's not
just a selling point but i'm also really
hoping they can tell the stories like
the Harlem Hellfighters that'd be a
really really cool group to look at and
see how like it affected them and how
they kind of were this on undersold
story during World War 1 i'm excited for
that setting for sure alright let's
shift perspectives and from the past of
the future call the duty infinite
warfare obviously got to jump on them by
about a week or so i think and the
trailer has had some thumbs down
probably a lot of those have to do with
the call of duty for packing deal that
they're doing i mean that's that's gonna
happen i guess and but do you think
maybe people are because i was intrigued
by infinite warfare i was at least
thinking oh at least they're trying
something new at least they're not like
resting entirely on another you know
slightly near future oh look this is the
same gun you're using now but now it has
a different magic future scope on it or
whatever i'm like frosting it into a new
sort of plane and hopefully like you
were saying iron actually making good on
in terms of gameplay and not just like
having it be a story setting and
basically be a normal first-person game
about veal was when you put the two of
them together now it looks like bad
phone is so much more intriguing but
what do you think about call of duty
infinite warfare and are you sort of do
you think it's a step in the right
direction for for activision and
infinity ward or do you think it's not
enough or or are we just being jerks
because all we've ever seen is two
trailers and at least they showed
gameplay kind of i think it's a game
that's become a little bit trapped by
its own success and i think they've been
not straying too far from their own
formula just because that's what sells
and they probably are have been given
marching orders to not change it too
much and that's why I'm a little bit
worried that this one will just be on it
like it'll be another plan it's sure but
it's just functionally going to be the
same thing
now I think it's pretty cool that it's
got a million thumbs down because to me
if I were making this game i would go to
my bosses and be like look this is a
mandate from gamers to change like we we
should try some new things check out how
many people don't like the fact that
this appears to be the same game I think
it's a positive thing and I think of
anything it could free them from having
to do the same thing every year now I
think you disagreed and said and it's
probably a truth it'll just depend on
sales right if it's if everybody thumbs
it down and it sells the same then sure
they'll just make another future future
warfare right next year like I mean I
don't know how there's nothing beyond
infinity but so they kind of put
themselves in a corner there yeah it's
it's it's I think you're right it's like
it's the successes of double that soars
I we sort of talked about a bit last
week and how do you really innovate a
series which is selling so well even if
it is like dipping a little bit and like
looking ahead to the future even more
you got to say that if battlefield one
is what we're talking about now then the
chances are the next next battlefield is
probably going to stay around that
period of time you'd imagine like oh
that's the perfect opportunity for them
to roll back into world war two and not
instantly be stuck like I wonder it's
sad to be talking about what they're
gonna do next after these but i wonder
if I guess it'll all happen on the
success of this whether or not there's
enough like gameplay change to make it
worthwhile Mike what do you think of
infinite warfare yeah I'm really hoping
because I mean I think in the way they
reveal the games is actually kind of
telling I mean it seems like dice and EA
showed us a lot more of battlefield one
then Activision Infinity Ward did like
in terms of gameplay at least I saw more
gameplay I'm I would you saw Morgan but
I think their trailer was twice as long
as what the public sold right right sure
um and I think I don't know I'm hoping
it's not just like a futuristic skin I'm
hoping they actually make like make use
of it because I don't know it'd be cool
that I don't know this is spitballing
what if you had a multiplayer map that
you're you're warping between different
parts that had like different time
travel differently there's different
gravity in different areas but there's
aunt there's zero grav combat according
to the trailer and they're showing it
but how much is it how much of that is
just going to be what was at the
beginning of ghosts where you're
floating and shooting people just like
you are in call of duty I want them to
actually use the setting to kind of
propel what they're doing forward rather
than just make the game and then throw
features like paint on it and
say you know like whether you said this
is one ak-47 would look like in 50 years
or something I don't want that I want I
want them to actually kind of tell its
story or use like deuce new cool new
things in multiplayer they couldn't do
like in black ops 3 like because the
wall running was just you know like from
remind me of tight and fall and then the
shooting remind me of every other call
of duty game I want them to actually
take the step that they're purporting to
be with this trailer I'm hoping it's
actually futuristic and not just paint
it to look like it I mean the other
thing as well is that like you can have
a temporary a contemporary war game be
really good and evocative like call of
duty modern warfare was called daddy for
mine warfare you just have to have like
a very well-written game with like
interesting set pieces and I feel like
we've had that in like black ops 1 for
instance I thought I had died and I
think the two modern warfare games did
personally I haven't really connected
with any like advanced warfare any of
those they were sort of like fun little
diversions like an action movie is but
like ISIL ago I still remember so much
colder before and and you know maybe
it's just a case of we look at these
games at this really superficial level
and actually when we get to play them
you know that's the that's the time for
these studios to be able to deliver what
they're actually trying to do and we
know maybe we judge maybe we judge this
game too early because we expect it to
do so little sure but then they've also
been doing that for a couple years
although if anything they've set
themselves up an environment where they
could do amazing things again like Mike
said with gravity give us the first
multiplayer map set on an aspherical
asteroid where I throw my date and hit
myself in the back of the head if I'm
not careful you know or like again give
me a space battleship where the the
multiplayer combat takes place both
inside and outside of the ship right
yeah I mean there's things that again
going back there sings at battlefront
and did a long time ago that we haven't
seen since and we haven't seen done
better and in this level of detail so
you know again if you're just going to
have the future ak-47 and a flat map
with Earth's gravity base people yeah
like then you really haven't innovated
at all yeah I guess we'll have to wait
and find out um yeah I mean I'm excited
for the two of them
I'm haven't been excited for called unit
in a in a little while I feel and I have
actually excited about this one
battlefield one obviously just the sort
of anticipation of what that could be is
obviously very tantalizing as well Mike
what about yourself what are you started
looking forward to and she put these two
games side by side I am looking forward
to both them as well I think more so
battlefield one just because mainly
because that series hasn't been where I
wanted to be for a long time so I'm
everything every time it comes out or
they show it off I'm hoping it'll get
back to what I loved about battlefield
these you know these prolonged more
multiplayer matches with more substance
because called Diddy's become this
twitch gameplay which I actually I like
it reminds me of like you know not the
same way that Counter Strike 2 but I
love counter-strike because it's a very
specific kind of shooter and I was
overwatch it's pulling from a lot of
them but I'm hoping that battlefield one
does add more substance to like returns
they succeed say the return to the roots
I hope they return to the right parts
and infant wharf i'm curious about but
battlefield one is the one that kind of
got me like really excited yeah iron
your big fan of battlefields you cover
Battlefield games here at gamespot all
the time and what do you looking forward
to added to these a battlefield one it
takes place at a point in history where
a lot of warfare was not figured out and
I think that's an exciting setting you
know like is it they started with
airplanes where they were just spotting
and then you know some bag of dicks
brought a shotgun with them okay and
then another guy brought a shotgun then
another guy brought a machine gun and
next thing you know you've got aerial
duels you know they invented a tank it
drove it three miles per hour so you
could just step out of the way if you
really want it to and they just invented
it to take on machine guns right and
really know how to use it I think that's
exciting it's exciting to set a game at
a point in history where it's not like
future ak-47 it's we don't know what an
ak-47 is but let's try making a rifle
semi-automatic and see what happens yeah
so that to me is a fun setting and still
allows for a lot of the weapon
customization that they'll sneak it in
yeah that they have in battlefield
already all right well in any case it
looks like we're getting too interesting
looking military first-person shooters
this year let us know that what you
think what are you love most looking
forward to call of duty infinite warfare
or battlefield one for your thoughts in
the comments below our good friends in
the twitch chat have all been screaming
at me for
call of duty disney infinity warfare and
maybe solve those two problems at the
same time and maybe not probably not
maybe that's what happens there's gonna
kill off I just read off the Disney they
bought Disney it's all over info crimes
bought Ubisoft and in broad disney and
and bought Activision and they're gonna
merge all together or down for else
indicated yep raymond and you're in your
call of duty video game
[Music]